so I want to ask you about how much
confidence it takes to be up there you
said something that Anthony Jackson told
you as encouragement a line that I
really like that quote on your worst day
you're still a bad
that's actually a a Steve
Gad quote and Steve used to tell that to
Anthony because Anthony used to get real
depressed if he did a wrong thing or not
perfect thing and Steve Gad used to say
this to Anthony Jackson and then Anthony
was my first bass Mentor or just Mentor
in general for people don't know he's a
legendary basist he's a legendary basist
and I I started playing the bass when I
was 17 and I moved to New York and I met
Anthony and he started mentoring me bit
in a very not typical way like he like
would just sit in his car with me for
hours and talk music and you guys just
listen to music and analyze it exactly
um and that was the best form of
learning I think just like well what are
you perceive here and well I heard this
and just discussing that um Jazz usually
or no old old styles of music and uh
yeah he told me that story about on your
worst day because you know like yeah
even then like when I was like 18 19 I
get sad sometimes about performances
like I could have done this it's like I
don't do that anymore thankfully or I'd
be miserable so you still you always
kind of feel pretty good yeah yeah now I
do now now it's just I I I sense the
body feeling fatigued especially if it's
a very long show like the ones I just
did with three-hour shows and we did you
know one to three hour sound checks so
that's a lot of physical activity every
day um so I just feel the body being
tired like fatigued the ears are
fatigued that's about it I don't really
reflect on the show much you're almost
like from a third person perspective
feel the body get tired and just accept
it yeah I don't want to identify with it
cuz then I'm like then then I'm tired
but I'm not tired I'm usually like
energized it's like with the food
poisoning the mind is still yeah capable
of creative genius even if the body is
gone yeah something like that yeah so no
self-critical component to the way you
see your performances anymore there is
uh there is critique but not in the way
that it would diminish my sense of self
it's different I can just kind of look
at something and be like okay well
actually next time I'll I'll do this
choice and this Choice maybe maybe this
would serve the song better um maybe
this would help uh the groove feel more
like this but it's not like I suck
because I did this and I'm a loser and
like do you think that's bad cuz I even
when I asked that question I had a
self-critical
thought then why' you ask that question
that's the wrong question I always have
the self-critical engine runting is it
necessarily A Bad Thing it depends if
it's affecting you negatively what is
negative anyway well if if it brings
your frequency down and you feel less
joyful inside and less you don't feel
like complete you feel less than less
worthy of something than you could call
that bad if you aspire to not feel that
way yeah I aspire to not feel that way
in the big picture but in the little
picture like there's a pain is a little
pain is good that's fair so confidence
you seem like in this performance you
seem confident you seem to be truly
walking the the bad way of
life I kind of a word that I prefer over
confidence is trust because I think with
confidence is almost the
like there's there a belief assigned to
it that I am this thing that you believe
in whereas trust is just simply knowing
that you can get up there and handle
whatever is going to come your way and
it's it's it's more of an open feeling
where it's like yeah I could I could do
this sure but not like I'm a bad
like you know what I mean
there a there's a huge difference
because I've shared the stage with
people who have a lot of confidence and
it can be like a brick wall just like
fear is a brick
wall so the brick wall is a bad thing
like the thing you have with Jeff here
on stage is not a brick wall there's no
walls there chemistry yeah how can you
explain that chemistry that the two of
you had trust and lack of fear yeah and
also I will say you know that uh each
individual has developed likes and
dislikes over their lifetime and that
can be like in this case we're just just
talking aesthetic likes and dislikes so
in this particular case obviously our
likes and dislikes are very much aligned
such that the things I do to compliment
him he enjoys and vice versa but it
could be two you know very trusting open
uh musicians on stage that don't have
walls up but their choices are very
different and one person likes heavy
metal and the other person likes
classical so it's it's got to be both so
you guys were good at like yes anding
each other musically like definitely is
that where you're
most at peace in a meditative way is on
stage um it used to be that it would
only be on stage it started with that
that was almost like my way in Flow
State and meditation was playing music
and then uh back in the day when I'd
kind of crash after shows I wanted to
change that I wanted to always feel like
I'm in Flow State so have you succeeded
I've gotten a lot better I'm still
obviously on the journey but yes so you
meditate I think you've said somewh that
you meditate before shows or just in
general I I meditate every day um when
I'm on tour with my band I ask that we
all meditate together for at least 20
minutes and I don't dictate what which
type of meditation I don't put on a
guided meditation CU everyone has their
own thing they want to do maybe someone
might be praying in their head it
doesn't matter it's just the idea that
we all put our phones down and we all
are in one room connecting energetically
spiritually and just letting Our Lives
go for a sec and and then we walk
straight on the stage and it's always
really connected and there were a couple
gigs where we ran out of time for that
and I could tell that was a there was a
major difference in the
performance so it both connects you and
centers you all those things yeah but
then when I'm home like I love to
meditate and I've tried various styles
of meditation and studied
various types of things so I I don't do
just one thing I kind of customize it
depending on where I'm at in my
life